calculate the ph at the half equivalence
point so let's just remind ourselves
what the half equivalence point even is
the equivalence point is when the thai
trend in this case the hydrochloric acid
completely reacts with the potassium
sorbate the thing that we are titrating
now the half equivalence point is the
point at which half of the potassium
sorbate has been converted to the sorbic
acid or another way of thinking about it
is the concentrations of the potassium
sorbate and the sorbic acid are
equivalent
well how do we relate that to ph and
what other information have they given
us to actually solve this
and a good thing to do
whenever you are if you feel a little
bit stuck here say well what other
information has they given have they
given us well they gave us the ka
of sorbic acid as being 1.7 times 10 to
the negative fifth so somehow can we
connect the ka of sorbic acid to the ph
at the half equivalence point well the
other thing that they give you is they
give you a whole series of formulas in
fact they give you a lot all the
formulas that i'm using here at the the
first couple of pages of the free
response section and even a whole bunch
of formulas on equilibria and on on all
of these different notations they use
and the one that might show up that
looks interesting
is this one right over here that you
might recognize as the henderson
hasselbach equation and it's actually
not hard to prove it it comes straight
out of the definition of ka and then
rearranging things and then taking
taking the negative log of both sides
and doing things like that i encourage
you to watch those videos on khan
academy if you are curious but what's
neat here is it connects ph it connects
ph
connects ph to pka
and the concentrations of the of an acid
and its conjugate base
so how do we how do we make a
relationship here
well
at the half equivalence point the acid
and the conjugate base are going to
their concentrations are going to be
equivalent so this so this and this are
going to cancel out you're just going to
get 1 and log of 1 is just going to be
0. so at the half equivalence point the
ph
is going to be equal to the pka
and so what is the pka here well they
told us that the ka
the k a
is equal to
and this is the ka of sorbic acid
ka absorbic acid is 1.7 times 10 to the
negative fifth
1.7 times 10 to the negative fifth
1.7 times 10
to the negative fifth and once again
when we're thinking about ka we're
thinking about the disassociation
constant for the acid and so that's why
we used sorbic acid there and either way
these two concentrations are going to be
the same and if i want to find the pka i
take the negative log of i take the
negative log of this so
p
k a which is equal to the negative log
base 10 of the ka and they actually give
you all of these formulas at the on the
first page this is going to be equal to
the negative
log
base 10
of 1.7 times 10 to the negative fifth
power and what is that going to be
let me get a calculator out
zoo
so let's see i'll write
one 1.7
this these two capital e's that's times
10 to the so times 10 to the
not the fifth the negative fifth power
now i want to take log base 10 that's
this button here if your calculator just
has a log button that's going to be that
defaults to base 10. so i'll take log
base 10 of that and then i want to take
the negative of that
and so this is going to be 4 point
approximately 4.77
so this is approximately
approximately
4.77
so the ph
ph is equal to pka which is equal to
that right over there